[Music]
I believe that we are biological beings
we are animals we have evolved from
countless ancestors each of those
ancestors in order to pass on their
genes had to survive and in some broad
sense of the term compete for survival
against others and against the
environment and had to be successful in
surviving in reproducing and as mammals
in protecting his or her offspring so
it's not surprising that we should have
an element of selfishness in us but it's
also a mistake to think that this
competition is a nature red in tooth and
claw kind of bloody conflict in which we
have to kill others sometimes we compete
more effectively by learning ways of
cooperating with others and then the
co-operative pairs or groups do better
so I think there is a biological basis
for both our competitive and sometimes
aggressive instincts and for our
cooperative instincts and what we need
to try to do if we're trying to fashion
a better society in which people can get
what they want more there's less
suffering is we need to think about how
to channel those innate behavioral
patterns into ones that will be better
for fostering cooperative and productive
relationships and will not foster the
aggressive competitive ones
I mean one reaction is just one of the
wildermann how people can get themselves
into this mess especially people who are
already comfortably off that they just
seem to want more and more that they can
they can't stop and they get into into
terrible trouble and you wonder why it
is that the money has so much value to
them or that you know because once you
have a certain amount really it can't
make much difference to your lifestyle I
take it that it's something else that's
driving them it's it's the desire for
public success or status or something of
that sort then must be getting them to
lose sight of what for any normal person
would be a balanced set of priorities
I don't think that greed in itself is
ever good I think that the desire to
succeed the desire to have more can lead
to people being more productive and
working harder but I think when it
actually turns into greed it's not good
for the person who is greedy it doesn't
conduce to their satisfaction with life
and it's always liable to spill over to
some of these consequences that we've
been seeing in in the last few months so
I would not say that greed is really
ever good although I would agree that it
could be a way in which some good things
happen but I would much prefer if those
good things happen because people care
about the good things because people
care about trying to be use a better
product which will make people's lives
better
that's certainly preferable motivation
I think that people may feel pinched as
compared as compared to where they were
last year without really being all that
badly pinched if they compare themselves
so to where they were five or ten years
ago so I think I know if it's philosophy
that's helping it's taking a bit of
perspective on your situation and of
course some people genuinely are pinched
some people have are not able to pay
their mortgages they've lost their job
the house will get foreclosed on them
you know I'm not really expecting those
people to be altruistic but most
Americans even in this downturn are
still very well-off they still live
comfortably they have a range of of
luxuries and if they compare their
situation with that of those who are
really poor the global poor they're just
incomparable II better off they spend on
trivialities like a bottle of water
which they don't need because the water
that comes out of the tap is safe to
drink
and yet the cost of that bottle of water
might be all that a family has to live
on for a day in in a developing country
I think people probably have or some
people have always taken what they can
get and it's simply that the
opportunities are different the size of
the economy is different the
possibilities are very different and so
you couldn't steal fifty billion dollars
before now you can but I don't you know
I really don't see human nature as
having changed very much in a short term
a human nature in my view is it's pretty
much constant and of course variable
from person to person and circumstances
to circumstance but but there's
something basic that underlies it that
displays itself in different ways in
different conditions
[Music]